today's question's from tracy in alabama
i have a rental property for which i'm
currently
holding a mortgage
i've been debating on refinancing you're
not holding a mortgage you owe a
mortgage okay
i've been debating on refinancing so i
can get rid of pmi that's good
i've read about a cash out refinance and
it seems there are some benefits that go
along with that is that a good idea
well tracy this is the dave ramsey show
where we talk about getting
out of debt not into more debt
because that is the shortest path
between where you are
and wealth cash out means you're going
to borrow more
than you currently owe you're going the
wrong direction miss tracy
and so uh no uh you you need to
refinance it and get rid of the pmi
or maybe you need to sell it
if you need some cash maybe you're too
broke to be a landlord
that's a possibility too real estate is
only a blessing
when it makes money well i rent it for
750 and my payment is 650. you are
losing money darling
i know it sounds like 100 profit but
it's not in the real world when you
count vacancy and credit loss meaning
they don't pay when they're supposed to
oh and by the way that 3500 heat and air
went out and you make 1200 a year it
takes you three years to recoup
that you're not making money on a
hundred dollar cash flow
you're losing money this is a liability
it is not an asset
your real estate is not a blessing it's
a curse sell it
if that's you if you've got a really
nice big fat cash flow then get the
stinking thing paid off and quit asking
me about borrowing more on it and going
further in debt that's going the wrong
direction kiddo
don't do that